i had a boyfriend that wouldn't use
straws because you thought it was too
much
it was not manly they didn't want to say
nothing
they can't put it in their mouth this
way oh we can't even eat bananas
regularly
you better break that banana because
that didn't come by the mouth i do it on
purpose
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to big mood
yeah
today we have our returning host guest
host guest host mr house nicki blake
guest ho
thank you it's always a pleasure being
in the house
thank you for having me welcome to the
house host what's up
who are we missing we're missing gina
yeah um
today we we typically shoot four
episodes in a day because we all have
other lives you know
so uh gina is actually out getting her
titties redone yeah
she's getting new boobs she was up for a
redo
on her tits and so we're we'll be happy
to have gina back with her new tits
later on we will showcase them later
right but in the meantime enjoy these
big naturals she got the big netties
over here
discussing how to make cleavage earlier
and i was like you can't relate
cannot relate yeah i've never had
cleavage ever actually one time this is
a very embarrassing story
my ex when i was like 21 years old he
was always talking about girls with big
teddies right and i'm obviously the
flat-chested one so
i one night wanted to try to impress him
we were gonna go out so i took my tiny
little titties
and i shoved those [ __ ] up as high as
i duct taped them together they were
like not
feeling they were suffocating they were
as high as i could get them and then i
filled in my bra with a bunch of [ __ ]
and i made it
like i had like d size just with my tiny
little egg cups shoved all the way up to
my neck
and he was like what are you doing oh no
that's so sad
it was really embarrassing because i was
like i just wanted to look cute
i like shoved my tits up as high as i
could he's like but i know it's all
empty in there oh
that's so mean i didn't even appreciate
the yeah the effort yeah
yeah just like you for who you were no
he really didn't never mind i tried it
sorry
but yeah so don't try to front is that
the guy that cheated on you
yeah he definitely cheated on me that
guy i heard him
all of my boyfriends cheated on me
except for two of them it's always the
ones you try the most with that
are yeah when you're trying to be like a
pick me like they don't respect you
they just smell it you smell it they
smell the desperation
so you're an a cup though yeah damn i
thought we were kind of the same size
but i always been like
between a b and c yeah you always say
you don't have booze but you have boobs
i feel i'm looking at boobs there's
boobs there yeah i see boobs on her
yeah they're a cup huh i think i don't
know
anyway this isn't a [ __ ] victoria's
secret
tester boobie victoria's secret used to
have those hella padded bras
huge boobs when i worked at hooters that
was all bombshell bra
i took a lot of guys yeah i had no
reason wearing that [ __ ] i was literally
like i fall asleep in class on my boobs
okay well anyways this episode i found
an article
because you know that's how i do and i
wanted to discuss with you guys
this is men are sharing things other men
do that pissed them off
and i thought that was a pretty
interesting take yeah even though we
don't have any men here to uh
speak their mind you know we have them
behind the camera we have them in
the nod at us if that's true yeah we do
have a male
behind the camera over here so he can
give us an email
it's your husband my husband did you
hear that
[Laughter]
it might be coming soon did you see a
picture in your head like oh yeah
if someone popped in your head you know
that let's proceed anyways
that means there's multiple ones
watching
excuse me nikki just cause you have a
husband don't mean that you gotta out
out
out my future ones future ones
not singular my future ex and future
future
[Laughter]
all right here's the first one let's see
i i haven't even really read through
these so i don't know if they're good or
not but we'll see
um okay so the first guy says so this is
coming from a man
what annoys him about other men having
to know everything or out expert each
other when did it become
unmanly to say i don't know dude true
have you guys experienced that
with men never being able to say they
don't yes it's really annoying it's like
it's okay to say you don't know
it's okay it's okay yeah um
steve sometimes we'll do the same but
this is different because
there's guys that are know-it-all guys
that i'm just like so annoyed by and
like can't stand to be around
steve does this thing where he is
confidently wrong
he's straight up doesn't know but he
doesn't know he doesn't know
he literally thinks he knows and he's
just wrong and so adamantly wrong
that's exactly what he's saying having
to know everything yeah but he
legit thinks he knows but then later i'm
like
no that was wrong that he doesn't know
yeah and he's like oh well [ __ ] i didn't
know it was wrong
that's a little endearing kind of sweet
it's cute it's not like the guys are
like no it's
no let me tell you i'll tell you why too
because
he finds out he's wrong he'll admit that
he's yeah yeah he'll be like oh [ __ ]
that example of when they list examples
to back up
the reasoning why they know what they're
saying is right man you know for the
most part
i'm wrong all the time and i know that
but i don't like to be corrected
so if he is a know-it-all yeah and he's
correcting me
on the one thing i know oh yeah
i'm like there's just one thing you're
right on everything else let me have one
yeah you don't have to be right all the
time just
bro let me have it i know it's not a
jack-in-a-box bag and it's an arby's bag
but just let it be a jump in the box bag
right now
just let it just let it be you know
what's my favorite part though because
you could tell
when they don't know because as they're
saying the answer
they're kind of stumbling on their own
words where they're like
trying to find what they're trying to
say but they have to say something as if
they know it
but they don't know it and you just see
right through it and you're like it's
okay
you can say you don't oh i'm tipped it's
okay
it's okay baby i didn't know anything
i've been talking about for the last 30
minutes
but i feel i feel like i'm comfortable
enough with you to let you know
that i feel like this is probably more
annoying like in the corporate world or
something
where like if you're working alongside
you know like yeah especially like in
front of the bosses and stuff like
there's never a wrong answer or
i don't know there's always just fill in
the blanks with something you better
know something
is this in the same universe as
mansplaining
not i think that's different it's a
little different i don't think males
notice other men mansplaining very often
probably so i think just
like this guy who's i guess complaining
about other men that annoys him
like maybe even he's like well i
actually do know more about cars than
you why are you acting like you know
that
right just because we're is it just like
a thing that guys always have to like
they have to know the answer like
you say something like yeah i knew that
but yeah yeah yeah what's crazy is that
this is going to be one of those
conversations where it's like
i'm not that guy there's going to be
people commenting on
because we know this isn't for everybody
i don't even think that your husband is
that guy because i've heard
casey say i don't know you know what i
mean like he'll be like
oh no i think i i i mean i for sure
he he does say that but i think i get
the credit why he says it now
she would not say it before like before
it was sorry training
am i alone in this case are you going to
nod or you're going to shake your head
good answer he played the fifth they
basically that's just what happened he
played the fifth yeah
to defend steve a little bit he does
that i i think it's endearing but
um he is like the first one to say he
doesn't know when he actually knows that
he doesn't know something he will say
i don't know well yeah that was him too
like back in the day when he would
always
like still have an answer for something
and i'm like it's okay if you don't know
yeah he'll eventually once he realizes
he was wrong he would easily
easily admit that he didn't know yeah
but
it's the initial reaction that they feel
like they have to know
it and i'm like it's okay you don't have
to know this
uh i would hate to be the guy next to
the next to that guy that's always right
in front of the boss you're like i don't
want to compete with you
but if i don't say something do i look
like i don't know
even though i do know like how do guys
in those settings
deal with that like you said like in a
corporate setting and the boss is there
and you're almost like
in competition and that's what i feel
like it's constant competition
and do you pick and choose maybe with
your girls it's different because i
would say like a lot of the guys we know
that aren't trying to sleep with us or
that we already sleep with they're like
yeah we could tell you like stop
you don't have to do that or they're
like our guy friends they're like mitch
i don't know because they're not trying
to impress us
yeah but how would you be like next to
the know it all
right i kind of feel like i am sort of
like a know-it-all i wasn't going to say
i'm like i'm like is that a man thing or
is that just a specific personality
personality thing yeah because like i
feel like i have an answer for
everything
almost everything same you know what
but now that you mention it now i
realize that that is that is true but
you know what
you are in a lot of corporate glass
shattered for you for me like i didn't
realize that before but now but you're
like oh yeah you're a total [ __ ]
nominee
when you brought up the corporate
setting it was like you worked in
corporate
maybe i got trained yeah you got
socialized to be
yeah i know it all with the other guys
that are know-it-alls yeah
my worst thing is i i hate when guys
lecture me on something that i know
about already honey don't get me started
but i think that's why i've been
vindicating myself on the poker table
because
there are [ __ ] dudes that will like
if i lose a hand people lose hands all
the time you know like guys go in big
and they lose a hand
if i lose a hand though a big a big pie
oh yeah they'll
get lectured by the older guys like you
know you shouldn't have done no no
no you could tell he had two pair boy
and then i take their money
do you lecture them back well they call
me sweetheart or some some stupid [ __ ]
and then i take my rack and i go
thanks sweetheart good night i go to
another table
that's for the money sweetheart yeah it
does it does
feel a little a little bit of revenge
that's how i feel like with sports
man i am shooting around and a guy tries
to act as though i do not know what i'm
doing
yeah i'm like sir what where'd you play
oh i'm sorry what you you weren't
recruited
you didn't play anywhere are you mad
because i could do this in heels
too yeah unless you're a professional
wait i know those
uh don't tell me what to do why are we
playing at the same table why why are we
here
why are we here right now i was like do
you want to see my
trophies my trophies prove that i know
what i'm talking but you know what
it's okay you could be right well do you
do you think that's necessarily a
negative thing or do you think like guys
innately they want to
be like the helper and like the teacher
and like do you
does it have to come from i feel
condescending
yeah well maybe if it's not
condescending right if it's just okay so
there actually was this older guy at the
poker table that i really respected like
he
was like i want to be him okay and he
like he's filipino we were talking about
the philippines
we were talking about my dad he actually
has the same name as my dad and
and i really liked him and i um i raised
i guess improperly like because i'm used
to online poker
and so on the tables i guess you're
supposed to put your chips out a certain
way
and i didn't and he was like hey just oh
so the dealer got messed up because i
didn't put him out a certain way and
he's like just so you know like
this is received as a string bet if you
do it like this
like you have to stack your chips like
this and then push and i was like oh
[ __ ] i didn't know thank you so that was
really helpful
but then tone is everything because that
didn't be like oh
like sweet how did you think that you
were going to have the wooden head
like clearly yeah didn't know what you
were doing stupid little
small brain i can't believe they let
women at this table but
there are times where you're like damn
like thank you or you're almost asking
for help and i think that's the
difference is like time and place
and tone that's a big thing because
honest mistakes are one thing but like
if you hit me with the sweetie or this
or it's the
kind of like trying to punk you i feel
like i deal with more of the men that
are like i'll play you one on one
yeah why do they want a punk woman
though
dude that kind of reminds me a little
bit about the the helpful thing it
reminded me of this one time we were at
the airport and this guy
like we were in the pre-check line which
means you don't have to take off your
shoes
when you go through the thing and this
one dude i saw him take off his
his shoes and he was wearing boots and
then i was like oh maybe it's his first
time going through pre-check i don't
know let me try to like help the guy
maybe he doesn't know so i'm like oh sir
just you know just so you know
we don't really have to take off our
shoes um but i was trying to be really
mindful of being as polite as i could
especially with strangers i am like
scared of speaking to strangers
and so um anyway so i try to tell him
politely and then he's as he's like
picking up his shoes he's like yeah i
know these are steel toe boots and i'm
like
okay i did not know apparently you're a
pro and you're
an expert sorry but it was just like
that was so unnecessary
that's what drives the desire for people
to just not talk to strangers
for community to fall apart because no
one can tell you anything
like but do you think that that's how
guys think we react
some i think some people are genuinely
trying to help and then others are like
clearly we know you're
that's not well that's how jess's
maintenance man thinks
you weren't here for that story and i
don't want to say it again okay okay
okay i i definitely
did you misread i went off oh you went
off i went home
she was wearing steel toe boots
what she was doing all right anyway
i want a list of you know so your pipes
are
not getting two things no but nikki
that's a really good point like to bring
up though
because then i'm pretty sure a lot of
men end up feeling that way
from women where like especially because
like we're so used to getting
that [ __ ] that now we're getting like
[ __ ] back yeah like maybe sometimes
we'll do it right we'll direct it
exactly when they don't deserve it when
it was like the intention wasn't there
it's like built up from all the men that
actually remain in such a shitty way
that like you
just nice one now is getting the brunt
of all of the years of the mansplaining
i definitely say sorry sometimes when
i'm wrong i'm like oh yeah
[Applause]
like 20. but but i've had weird i mean i
mean i've had weird things happen to me
where guys like come up to my window or
they're being on my window or like i've
had situations you're so hot
yeah irresistible you're trying to not
be single no more you know what i hit on
everybody i need to stop
you know played sports male dominated uh
arena
now you're in another male dominated
arena you were in a male dominant i was
in a male-dominated arena with comedy
and poker like now
it seems like everything i pick is male
dominate jk's male dominated you know
do you think that maybe yeah like maybe
it gets built up and maybe like we
are kind of socialized to be like
ongoing our tank is full of them
definitely from now being in radio and
being around the boy i mean you know
tim rick and then i have greg and benny
i'm literally just surrounded by men
24 hours a day i would actually say now
in this environment it has caused me to
be
softer a lot softer than it was when i
was in the club and i was around other
women i mean
sometimes when you're in that setting it
is a competition around men at their
worst
in a bar and a club they're at their
worst i'm dealing with the bottom of the
bear
like do you drunk you're trying to grab
a booty because now you're with dads
but i also notice getting out of toxic
environments and yeah i'm now around
guys but i
catch myself being more feminine than i
was before because i'm understanding
the energy exchange like watching men
interact with each other
and then realize oh this is just how
y'all are and you're not interested in
me mind you i'm around men that
don't want me they are taken that makes
it a little easier
to put your guard down yeah and it's a
different experience because i'm not
worried about being sexually
you know yeah i'm not looked at through
those lenses
and that makes it easier to kind of go
into a softer role i'm a lot quieter
i feel like i'm way more relaxed but
when the gaze is on and somebody's like
you
know yes yeah yeah they're putting it on
thick
that's when the aggression comes out
because that's a defense mechanism
of physically being harassed by men
so it's almost like the puffer fish
method right i puff my chest out to let
you know like don't do that and if they
get rejected
they start get that's when they start
getting all condescending and yeah
so you know again there are times where
i need to let that guard down
and that's normally when i'm with people
that can protect me but if not like yes
it's gonna stay on it's just a defense
mechanism
but i will [ __ ] you up don't try me
don't don't take that lightly because
you just have to be ready you never know
it's a crazy time but
in the workspace i would say i get to be
a lot more softer i get to be a lot more
talking about having that tank full
you know like when you're just like
flooded with a lot of emotions that's me
you should often basis well you should
check out talkspace
because it's mobile therapy you can
always contact
a therapist right from your phone it's
really cool because
talkspace is actually a fraction of the
cost of in-person therapy
it really is and instead of waiting for
an appointment you can just send
unlimited messages
to your therapist 24 7 and they'll
engage with you daily
five days a week i wholeheartedly
recommend talkspace for therapy because
you always need someone to talk to you
know it's always really important to let
those
emotions out and then have them guided
through someone that's a professional
that can help you work out those issues
yeah not
dumping them on your friends all the
time yeah that's exhausting
so it's really cool because you could
sign up online and start therapy the
same day that you sign up you can text
video or send voice messages to your
license therapist so it's incredibly
convenient
to have virtual sessions from the
comfort of your own home you don't have
to like drive to the actual
office talkspace has thousands of
licensed therapists with years of
experience in over 40 specialties
including depression anxiety substance
abuse trauma anger management
relationship issues food and eating and
so much more and they even do
couples therapy too oh wow yeah as a
listener of this podcast you'll get 100
off your first month with talkspace to
match with a licensed therapist today go
to talkspace.com make sure to use the
code
mood to get 100 off your first month and
show your support for the show
that's mood and talkspace.com all right
and our
next sponsor is apostrophe which is a
prescription skincare brand
have you ever had a breakout come like
right at the worst time
i feel like every time my period comes i
get the
statistics this is exactly coming and
then but like
i still want to be cute and it's just
like so annoying because i had never had
anything to
like help me deal with that monthly
issue
because i was just using like
over-the-counter stuff but that's
sometimes not
is always the right answer um well
apostrophe is a prescription skin care
company that offers
science-backed oral and topical
medications sometimes you need
like an oral medication in order for it
to go through your body you know not
just something topical
yeah inside and out so they have both
they're clinically proven to help clear
acne
apostrophe will connect you with a
board-certified dermatologist who will
create a personalized treatment plan
that's perfectly tailored to your unique
skin that's another big thing if you're
using an acne treatment that's
maybe works for someone else it doesn't
work for your skin over the counter
stuff it's hit or miss
simply fill out apostrophe's online quiz
about your skin goals and medical
history then snap a few selfies and your
dermatologist will
create your customized treatment plan we
have a special deal for our audience
save 15 off your first visit with the
board certified dermatologist at
apostrophe.com
big mood when you use our code big mood
this code is only available to our
listeners
to get started go to apostrophe.com big
mood click
begin visit then use our code big mood
at sign up and you'll get
15 off of your dermatology visit that's
a-p-o-s-t-r-o-p-h-e
dot com slash big mood and use that code
big mood to get your dermatology visit
and save fifteen dollars
we thank apostrophe for sponsoring this
podcast thank you
what's the next one that men get pissed
off about
i was kind of surprised on some of these
because i felt like they i
i as you all were talking a little bit i
clicked through a few because i hadn't
checked this out previously but so i was
reading i was like oh
um when men say they are babysitting
their own children
so obviously that pisses off women right
but i didn't know that other men
recognized yeah
they're insane so like this list is kind
of making me feel positive because i'm
like
yes thank you like y'all are saying this
is wrong
yeah yeah i was just talking to steve
about this when
um when the dad like stays home with the
kids one night
and everyone's like oh my god what a
great dad it's like the mom does it
every single day
and it's never like mom's such a great
mom it's like it's just expected but dad
gets like
accolades for it never understood that i
had to stay at home dad and my mom
worked
but even my mom sometimes when other
women see that's the thing to other
women would be like oh my god he's
always with the baby and cooks like wow
you settled for less doesn't mean he's
that great right
and that's why when i see some of the
i'm thankfully i'm around a lot of men
that are great fathers
so yeah i totally have heard that that
should be the baseline like yeah i i
get it i feel like i get it if like the
man is working like
the entire like he's with the sole
breadwinner the woman's not working at
all and so like once in a while she gets
the day off and he takes care of the
kids
after working yeah that's a total sugar
baby
yeah exactly this modern times
both are working full-time jobs man both
parents need pats on the back sometimes
hey shout out to the grandparents i'll
be helping out with you yeah
seriously you know they're already
finished and then they have to start all
over
though y'all better stay healthy
because i'm gonna need a babysitter yeah
i don't know my mom is not around so i'm
like i don't think i can do it
no i don't think i can handle it oh yeah
oh oh we'll be there we'll be the
grandmother
you will be there you will be there i'll
go to texas
auntie nicki's in town
okay let's see um guys who behave
desperately around women and won't stop
hitting on them even when they're
clearly not interested
thank you i'm surprised you guys noticed
that do they step in though
that's the issue that i have is they
don't go hey dude
some of them do something yeah yeah
steve will especially if the woman looks
super uncomfortable and harassed but
steve will do it in a funny way too yeah
he disarms the guy
yeah he does which is because he's not a
fighter yeah it's just
it it looks pathetic to those guys
because i've been around guys commenting
on like dude this guy has no game listen
to this guy
trying to hit on this girl it's just sad
yeah
if i go out and i have a guy friend i
say look we leaving
you're my man we're together somebody
hits on me let them know
that we're together so that's like the
natural deflection like
sorry bro she's good
or sometimes you'll see like i've seen
guys maneuver like
what about what about that girl you know
like yeah like maybe
you see an eye oh wow they like veer
them off into the
they're like look that way yeah or you
know the bartenders the male bartenders
that
pay attention and they'll like hey can
you gu are you okay i know like recently
there was a viral story about this
bartender that sent like a receipt
supposedly a receipt to a girl and then
but he actually wrote on it saying
something like
put your hair up in a ponytail if you if
you want like if this guy's making you
feel uncomfortable
yeah yeah i like that those spaces again
club life alcohol you see people
sometimes
some know what they're doing and they're
being forceful and aggressive and some
are
literally like they don't actually have
a clue like they lack that social
awareness
some just don't know but when the girl
is like again we don't know how to
always
like boundaries or sometimes it's like
nah i'm good well it's kind of scary
it is you know what kind of guy you're
getting yeah and
when some guys get rejected they get
very aggressive and that's why it's
nice when those guys can kind of see a
situation and especially they're
literally like the leader of
the mood at the bar or you know like
security guards or
you know places where you can actually
get help
ladies don't be afraid to let somebody
know that you feel uncomfortable like
let the security guard know like hey
this guy is following me or
even had a i've done that before at
target because i had a guy follow me
around the store yeah he followed me
around the store and i
felt him following me so i purposely
went into the underwear aisle
and he went into the underwear aisle as
well
so i knew he was clearly following me so
i let security
know i actually let one of the employees
know i acted like i was asking for help
for something
and i told him i was like i think this
guy is following me can you can you
watch me
i don't feel comfortable they're like
yeah not a problem well actually loss
prevention is watching you on cameras
anyway
yeah but just kind of like i don't know
it all back right
like just let you know let's see if you
want to know it all actually no cameras
are on you
so actually with that being said they
were watching and they're like yeah he
is following you we're going to make
sure that security follows you to your
car
thank god thank god because security
hold on security followed me to the car
and then the guy like ducked off and
then came back to my car
and then the security guard came running
because he was waiting he's like i'm
gonna wait what am i gonna
did he look homeless or normal no he
looked like a he
looked like a younger guy and then he
said i was just trying to ask if you
wanted to smoke with me and i'm like no
no so if you ever feel uncomfortable
like
don't be scared that's another thing too
we gotta learn like
let somebody know because yeah if i
didn't tell someone
i could sound crazy like yes really did
he really come up to you yeah in the
middle of the day like are you serious
we're not really believed a lot like
you're not
so and the security guard saw it and
actually because who knows oh my god
why would you come around so
aggressively like that like wait no i've
seen videos
of of them sneaking into the back a seat
of people's cars
like when the girl goes to return the
shopping cart they get in the car
because the door's still unlocked oh no
yeah well my car when you unlock it only
the driver like you have to
double that's good do it for the other
three to open some wild videos yeah i'm
like i hope that girl's still alive yeah
so that's why if you feel like
somebody's watching you or that
uncomfortable like even winking at the
part like
yo what's up somebody yeah yo somebody
you know what i do too
because i feel like i've had the the not
taking the hint i
facetime like as many guy friends that i
have i'll be like somebody pick up this
phone like
i'll facetime so i have a list yep so i
have somebody's mail like a male face
like i am cared about
you know what you should have on your
phone is a video screen recording of a
facetime call
yeah you could just play it right and it
looks like wait i've seen that they have
that stuff in an uber
oh they do yeah
if you feel like your uber driver is
actually stealing you yeah they have
like a recorded thing that you can
play like it's like scripted so you can
talk back to it yeah
shout out to the guys that acknowledge
that that [ __ ] is wrong yeah
there's help out someday yeah there's
predators and heroes to be hyper
vigilant
thank god you were aware of your
surroundings thanks dad no my dad
literally put me up like
let me know off tops always to be aware
know my exits no those things be able to
sense you got to know if somebody's
following your car like it's crazy the
amount of things that we just have to
know
to stay safe oh my god this morning jess
was listening
like when we the first thing that
happened when i woke up this morning
steve shows me this meme like he's
laughing in bed and i always get annoyed
because i'm like tired and he's like
he's laughing at memes and stuff and i'm
like what and then he
shows me and it's uh and it's this this
like
meme script of this like uh the guy goes
like oh
god burglar comes up and says give me
your wallet
and i i bust so and so rounds of ammo in
him and then i realized
it would have been cheaper to give him
my wallet and i was like
men are just worried about their wallets
when they get pulled up at gunpoint like
they're not worried about
wow
i'm like oh my wallet sure take my
wallet
clenched up tight it's not scary at all
no woman on this planet is worried about
her wallet
when like a [ __ ] man comes up behind
her that must be nice
i mean there are purse snatchers sure
but most of the time we're like oh
they're trying to rape me
i'm like thank god he only took my purse
yeah yeah yeah thank god
it was a knockoff and
my card is overdrawn and yes
[Music]
oh my god that's hilarious okay um
here's another one
um guys don't like it uh men who think
it's unmanly to drink delicious
cocktails
why is it suddenly unmanly to have a
sweet tooth when it comes to drinks
i was just watching how i met your
mother and marshall was just complaining
about that exact same thing
and then every time he tried to get like
a girly cocktail like lily his wife
would come in
and she'll be like oh thank you honey
he's like oh man
i wanted that one i had a boyfriend that
wouldn't use straws
because you thought it was too much it
was not manly
[Applause]
they don't even oh the guys are taking
the bananas they cut the piece of banana
yo loki or they chew the popsicle from
the side
they can't put it in their mouth this
way oh we can't even eat bananas
regularly
you better break that banana because
that didn't come by the mouth i do it on
purpose i like
it in the kitchen and i'm like sexy
we all grabbed bananas and went to the
park right now do you know what that
looks like
we should do that as an experiment just
all of us go to a park and sit there we
each
unpeel the bananas slowly and sexually i
just watch who's watching
a b-roll of the surrounding to see the
guys would be like they'd be like
in a line we're in a little girl's
eating a banana like we're all together
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're going to do that just eating
popsicles and having random pieces which
piece of uh food do guys react to the
most
four groups that's an experiment that's
only a popsicle
because a banana you have to bite it off
a popsicle you're sucking yeah
very true i could suck a banana
i could bite a popsicle
turn that [ __ ] into baby
[Laughter]
it starts off so sexy and then she what
if she doesn't even peel it she just
bites them with the peel off
she's like i've been feeling
i don't know not cougary because it's
not like younger guys
but um do you feel like since you've
been married like i just don't
care anymore like if guys are like oh
what are you doing like i just don't
care just be living my life
like a nipple a nibble
i don't care what it looks like to you
yeah like i used to be very concerned
because i don't really like that
sexual attention um but now i'm just
like they're not gonna do anything i'm
married like he's like around here
somewhere probably
probably maybe he's at the bar somewhere
somewhere yeah he comes back so what are
you doing
like i'll change in my car like i used
to be so like
but now i'm just like i don't give a
[ __ ] they saw a bra whatever
yeah i don't think i'm there yet girl
she was like that's a you
like because i sometimes change in my
bedroom with the
curtains open and there's other windows
across the parking lot
oh yeah we can see and i'm like oh so
they saw like a little blurry image of
half a bra i don't give a [ __ ]
that's kind of hot no dude i'm still so
paranoid because in my closet there's a
tiny little window
yeah i thought so too but it's really
nice it's a natural light natural light
it's super cute yeah but i have my
clothes hanger
like the yeah it's called a clothes
hanger right i have it right in front of
it so i have a whole bunch of stuff on
it
but i'll still change in the closet but
i get really low
where no one can see me outside the
window but it's funny because my
neighbor's across the street and the
window that can see
inside the closet it's the window from
like the stairs so it's like
they have to be on the stairs so far
away like there's no way they could ever
see me at all but i'm always like
changing like this tip is like if they
get turned on by
half a bra from a mile away good for you
oh you did somebody for you somebody had
an erection from
from a little flash of a bra from that
far
she's doing it on purpose now right
she's trying to get her good deeds
changing like good for you
i think i just get worried like if
someone like i've seen too many um
creeper movies where they're like
obsessive and like peeping toms and like
they become used over time because
they've been watching you
in the in the [ __ ] window for months
changing and then one day they're gonna
come get you
well they say there's always one naked
neighbor and if
you are the nickname you don't have you
don't have one and it's you yeah i guess
it's probably
your name because i'm the naked neighbor
i'm the
yeah but i guess back to the cocktails i
do find myself
laughing if a guy's like can i have my
tie please you know i'm like you do
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Applause]
i don't know why because i know it
doesn't make sense but
it is weird to me but then i'm like oh
no it's your i like i'm like that's the
i don't know is that in like the mystery
pantry or yeah
and then i stop myself but my initial
reaction is to go
you know like i take my whiskey i drink
my tequila straight up
what are you doing but um yeah they're
delicious
though but you remember the french guy
that i dated yeah like when we would i
would go out to the bar he would only
order [ __ ] girly ass
like cosmos like the girl
but he was the best sex
i was so wrong on that but what pissed
me off when steve and i first started
dating is
because he all he loves salads he loves
salads i hate salads yeah that's weird
and so i would always order a real meal
at the restaurant she's like can i get a
lasagna
i'll have a salad yeah and but the
waiter would always give me the salad
i'm like ah
i didn't order that [ __ ] food burnt
food over here
that's triggered shredded
[Laughter]
french fries yo i'm so mine don't judge
you on the food my dad's a big ass dude
i grew up around
big ass men who probably did things on
purpose to try to get people to fight
them because they were like
always looking for a fight i tried to
bait yo my dad wears pink
was a stay-at-home dad likes foo foo
girly drinks and he always
he was always like yo side note those
are the ones that get you wasted
more like so be careful when you're out
there
because they're sweet they're easy to
drink he goes my dad will hold a pina
colada
in a pink lava lava
two pigtails in his hair and be like
does anybody have anything to say right
now probably not so i'm like
but i would do what you did if i was on
a date
with a man for the first time and a
pina colada or a daiquiri with the
whipped cream on top of it showed up
i would ask why i would have questions
weird like you meet a man for the first
time and he orders a drink and it's the
bitchiest drink you've ever heard of on
the menu that to me is like
new like i i wouldn't even register that
at all yeah
me neither i think i always dated
comedians and so
they're just kind of silly anyway mm-hmm
yeah i don't i typically don't date
silly people but i
i take very seriously yeah i probably
should yeah you should
dabble in it yeah i'm gonna dabble in
silly a little bit more i think i
i am i'm a judgy person wondering why i
watch people when it comes to food i'm
very
oh yeah you gotta mean nicki streety
yeah you're a foodie
yeah but again if you have an
explanation or like a story behind it
i'm always gonna ask like oh why
or that would give you a chance right
do you always drink pina coladas right
i'm like i'm such a [ __ ] when it comes
to alcohol that
i would see any cocktail as like oh man
that's strong you're you're [ __ ]
you're you're crazy
but i'd be the first one to get you
drunk i'd be like oh that's cute drink
that daiquiri
yeah you want another one you want a
shot i'm not afraid i'm the shot friend
i'm like
no girl i'm the shirt i am i'm like it's
okay you're safe with me
but you know i think to stop drinking
after sharing that with you
stop drinking it was the last time
you're welcome for one of the best
days so fun it was so fun i had the best
time for you
i carried her by the way i'm a good
friend i'm not leaving you just in the
middle of now that was the best time
ever
but because i it was like such a good
time that i'm like i've had my fill for
like a decade
yeah it's like i'm scared it's a really
good time i'm a good time
do you know what drink looks really
pretty but it'll [ __ ] you up as an amf
uh tokyo teas but it's like
it's bright blue [ __ ] yeah and i
thought that was basically
no it's like basically it's a long
island iced tea so it's
all the alcohols but with blue curacao
on top instead of coca-cola
and it is beautiful and will get you
passed out but if you're broke
uh that's a perfect drink all night
what about l.a water oh that's only um
at a certain
chain right i've never heard of that i
don't know it's it's almost the same
it's like la water it's like a type
it's along the line it's like more gray
looking yeah it is great looking yeah
but if you ever only had it at bj's
brewery
i like to drink i had at a club once it
was way too strong i'm like
well i've been eating a lot of food
lately yeah but it's been getting
delivered to my door
and i've been cooking it myself with
hellofresh hello fresh is easy and
stress free
i don't have to be a five-star oh sorry
three-star michelin chef there you go
baby
three-star michelin chef to get some
good food in my house
it went from being like a a bottom
basement
uh c-rated restaurant in here to an
a-rated restaurant
uh hello fresh a-rated red
a-rated a-rated one-time when i worked
dinner
yeah no health hazards in here
because they're the freshest ingredients
and they deliver uh high quality
pre-portioned ingredients too so you can
make meals that are delicious and
nutritious
over 90 of ingredients are sourced
directly from farmers to ensure only the
freshest produce
and proteins are delivered right to your
door it's also flexible for your
lifestyle you can easily change your
delivery days
and food preferences and you can skip a
week whenever you need so
uh i like it my husband likes it those
are the only two people in this house
the cats don't get any of it because
we're greedy
i have an order coming on tuesday [ __ ]
brag about it i'll tell you which one
i'm really excited are you getting that
[ __ ]
which one because oh my god the
shepherd's pie was good i'm trying to
eat a little bit healthier now so i try
to choose not
like the most crazy ones but there's
this ginger plum chicken that looks
really good
and guess what pork chops i'm gonna get
to make pork katsu i'm gonna try that i
can't wait
get america's number one meal kit by
going to hellofresh.com
big mood 14 and use code big mood 14
for 14 free meals including free
shipping again go to hellofresh.com
bigmood14 and use code bigmood14 for 14
free meals including free shipping yeah
totally worth a meal you need a week off
from thinking about groceries
and all that [ __ ] i just don't want
to just try a couple of boxes
it really makes your week easier it
elevates your lifestyle
and after you're done eating all that
delicious food
you want to take it out of your mouth
right you want a clean
what are mouth gonna put in my mouth to
help me clean my mouth what you should
put in your mouth
is bruce mmm electric toothbrush oh that
thing is
bomb yeah you have it i have one yes and
they have all these different settings
you can go for your daily the whitening
for your gums your tongue
everything is amazing yeah so there's
six unique
modes to customize your brushing
experience i like to clean your speeds
yeah
keep going i'm listening it's really
cool because the brush head
behind it has like little bumps in it
and that's what you can use to like
clean your tongue too and there's a
tongue mode and a gum mode
it's really cool i really like this
toothbrush and also it's so stylish it's
like aesthetic it looks so good on your
countertop
millennials love aesthetics yes it has
uh it has a
magnetic base to charge it and it comes
with a super stylish
travel like travel container like a
travel case
and it's really i am a big fan i really
love it and it's also
i don't know if they have different
colors but mine's all black i got the
all black ones
yeah and the battery life is so long i
haven't even had to charge it yet
yes it lasts forever so
it's actually a four week battery life
jesus
yeah four weeks and they also have a
subscription program so you never forget
to change your brush head ever again
bruce ships you new replacement heads
every six months so you're never stuck
using a worn down brush head
i love that brush's electric toothbrush
has a modern aesthetically pleasing
design comes in seasonal colors
oh sorry there's seasonal colors but i
have a black
black one looks good yeah and it'll look
amazing wherever you take it
so get 15 off your brush toothbrush kit
and refill plan when you use promo code
mood
at bruce.com that's 15
off using promo code mood at
b r u s
once again go to bruce.com and use code
mood for 15
off your brush toothbrush kit and refill
plan
get those teeth clean but make sure you
put it in your mouth before you turn it
on
[Laughter]
all right let me see let me find another
one there's there's a ton of them here
i'm trying to pick out the best one this
one
i'm surprised and uh that guy's noticed
this but yeah if any dude
unironically so on purpose yeah and
seriously
uses the term alpha or beta when talking
about people it's a red flag so i know
that
we've used those terms like they're in
the lexicon
they're in the conversation but i always
used it earlier because i was like well
they're
you know men versus men is going to be
alpha versus beta yeah
like things that annoy each other is
there uh
taking that literature too far type of
maybe usage of alpha beta i would have
to hear it in a sentence
because if you're using it like like
we're talking about right now like it's
kind of
definitively like definition-wise it's
it's more
practical not like you're putting
someone down using it
you know like if it's like it's just a
term that makes it if it's an alpha guy
being
like yo this little beta [ __ ] you know
like that
or like a beta guy being like you know
like
okay alpha macho blah blah blah like
that's a different context do you guys
think that alphas and betas exist
because i've read a lot of things now
where people are saying like that
doesn't actually exist men
are a combination of all of it at
different times yeah
people are on their lives for sure but
are there outright alphas and
outright betas yeah in your experience i
think so
i think so for sure there's people that
innately want to take charge and have
leadership roles and
this it has nothing to do with asserting
yourself on other males i think there's
i think the definitions have gotten
skewed to like that's probably what it
is yeah
to be a little bit more toxic because i
feel like alpha gets talked about in a
very toxic manner these days rather than
like what it truly is
is like stepping up to a leadership
position empowering other people around
them
you know and then the beta roll is is is
also tarnished because it means you're a
little [ __ ] a little nerd guy
and and sometimes the beta role is just
being a supportive role it's just like
you're the you're still necessary in a
group setting you're just
you're not the one giving commands
you're the ones that's going to deliver
this right
orders and and both are great but
they've gotten skewed
i can say i can see where they would be
annoyed hearing that like the improper
use of that yes
almost like when you hear simping like
somebody yeah we're like
first
so i feel like that's like the
equivalent of saying like he's a beta
like
using like there's these words that
they've decided amongst each other like
that
it's like just being a gentleman makes
you a simple yeah right that's [ __ ]
in the girl
in the women's world do you think it's
like women calling other women a hoe
just because she's sexually confident or
you know like sometimes like you're just
jealous of that person's
use of them so people are like yeah they
use it to take down something that
they're jealous of right so i could
totally
i again i see how annoying that could be
you're like
bro seriously here here goes tom again
talking about how much he's an alpha and
he don't do this for his woman
you know i don't do that like i'm never
like yeah i can see that being extremely
annoying
because we all know that there's levels
there's layers we're more than one thing
like there's moments like
if he is an alpha in public
and he decides he wants to let his guard
down around his woman that doesn't make
him a [ __ ] yeah
he's at home like let him live but i can
see how
now with we're so involved in
everybody's lives
we're not only seeing what they want us
to see like we're seeing how they are at
home
how they're in relationships so some of
these guys see their
friends with girls and be like oh he's
such a beta like what a beta [ __ ] or
talk [ __ ] about it
and that would piss me off yeah
constantly being
judged by my friends and my femininity
or my
masculinity is always in question
because it's different
depending on who you're around like it
should be different you should have a
different relationship with your
your spouse or partner than you do with
your buddies that you go play
pool with yeah you want to speak to your
grandma the same way you would speak to
your husband
yeah that'd be a weird ass conversation
with grandma
grandma you want bananas
somebody stop sucking all those bananas
dude mushy ass bananas
i am eating nothing banana flavor from
we did just purchase bananas for
crafting
yeah we're gonna for crafting and
crafting
i swear on everything you said we're
crafting over here
i was like we gonna paint
then there were sausages and i was like
okay so are we are these the snacks
we're going to make we're making
necklaces yeah the crab why is it called
a craft table
i don't know why it was craft macaroni
yeah when you started it
in the movie sets yes on set there's a
craft crafty yeah they call it crafty
it's just like where
it's just like the little snack table
for the people that are filming and so
it's just weird to call it crafty i have
no idea where that originated
okay i have a question because i got
corrected by somebody
the other day by a man who corrected me
because of course you did
i said it apparently wrong is it craft
do you always put emphasis on craft when
you say it correct wait what correct
what are you talking about
because i've said it before like so can
i get a craft
i didn't realize it said oh and i said
oh can i get a craft of
tea or something like that and he's like
oh so i didn't want to
a craft it's i say carafe correct
yeah and i i never knew
you just said crap so in order you'll
just read it right
well no i've never i've never read it
never once have
so he goes i really don't want to
correct you
that's a nice way to correct someone you
could you could correct me yeah you
start then you start that way yeah
and he goes i just say this because
you're you talk about food a lot
so here's the definition of the word
and that's how it's spelled i was like
and then you're sitting there like i've
been saying this [ __ ]
wrong so i didn't know if everybody knew
that it was
correct well it's confusing at the bar
because you get a carafe
of wine or or mimosas but then you have
craft beer
coffee cocktails they're crafted like by
an artist
which is a different word of bio biopic
so david uh he kept swearing that biopic
was pronounced biopic yeah and then he
went into this whole
rant about like why it's exactly
pronounced that way and then he read
this whole article
we actually vlogged this on our channel
and this is back when we were camping
many years ago
and then everyone in the comments are
like i read that exact same article and
it explains
why it's pronounced biopic yes
yeah so he read it wrong yeah and like
he was
he was willing to die on that film like
biopic
that's one of those words that like if
you've always read it but never heard
anyone say it out loud cause like i
in until i moved to la i never heard
anyone say biopic out loud
but then it makes sense too because it's
a biographical
yeah yeah picture if you think about it
yeah but i don't know if you're just
reading
yeah i never trouble with that a lot
because i read way more than i talk yeah
and
so uh there's been so many words like i
that i've said and people have laughed
at me but i'm like me too
like okay i said sway to him because
yeah because the way it spelled i always
in my head
i had never said it out loud and i've
never heard anyone say it
wait it's pseudonym oh yeah
i'll never make the mistake again i got
it like everyone on the internet
corrected me
but i like it became a joke after that
but i yeah
like i i just read the word i never said
it
i remember um it was it was really funny
on jk news it would always make fun of
me for saying
um uh [ __ ] what was it uh siblings
that one yeah siblings siblings sibling
instead of siblings siblings yeah i
don't know if i'm still i still can't
hear them
say it again sibling yeah you're right
sibling
no no that's how i used to say siblings
no no like miriam's or whatever
no so people kept tweeting me this when
they when they added it to the
dictionary because they all remembered
that
is the definition the wrong way to say
supposedly no
it's the supposedly definition it was
this petty ass person that got corrected
and so made sure
that they would get hired at the
dictionary i got money and i'm taking it
all the way to webster yeah
we're getting this in the dictionary
there are so many words
i grew up english is hard my dad still
speaks pidgin like
okay english is not your first language
yeah with an accent like yes it's
english but it's so
mixed up with so many other languages
that there's times where i have no idea
that i said something wrong
and i just know it because it i read it
like i was like oh
okay i've seen the word and so i'm kind
of like the opposite if i see it then
i'm like oh okay that makes sense but
i've
if i've never seen the word and
you're saying it to me i'm not here i'm
i'm only here you're only hearing
sounds yeah craft is a prime example of
that because every time i've ever said
it or been around people i've never
heard the
the little chronograph yeah never
because they say it so fast
i've never once heard that and even if i
was to say like ask my
dad that's the last person to ask
because he would be like yeah i don't
[ __ ] know what that is
that's not one thing to hold all the
juice in it
by the way my dad's super smart but just
chooses to speak in pictures all the
time
and i pick up on it so there's you can
be smart
yeah people don't understand that yeah
so when we talk amongst each other
and i know i'm on the radio in san
francisco
yeah i read things and i get corrected
so often because one of my co-hosts
was an english major that's worse than
me
wow but i lean into it right yeah
you gotta you just gotta play it saw i
seen it
i seen it right i'm never gonna say i
saw it
well there's times i'll be like oh yeah
that makes sense i saw it or i will
naturally say i seen it and like you
said it is a class thing it has a lot to
do with like where you grew up
and so now i just feel like you already
you already know i don't seem to date
and i don't know
how
because either you lean into it or you
feel embarrassed exactly
so i have to talk to um the talk to text
and when i get certain articles sent
over to me one thing i do is because in
order for me to pronounce it correctly i
have to hear it so
i'll read something like you but because
i
read more than i'm speaking yeah and
using that verbage
i'll have it read to me yeah so that i
can hear it and once i hear it i'm not
afraid to say the
said in my own voice when i'm reading it
so many times that i i didn't even know
what it is yeah and the the worst the
most embarrassing one
is that i said a guy got subpoenaed and
what he's
and people are laughing i'm like what
and they're like
he got white like he got stupid
i read an article
oh my god i don't know what you're
saying
my ass didn't know i was like
okay how long was he what his siblings
are but
he is not supposedly supposed
to be it wasn't his fault
the esthetician right the aesthetician
you know what i'm saying
man i hate when people know the word and
they know you don't know how to
pronounce the word so they keep
saying the words like huh do what he did
what now
dude even even though i'll learn how a
new word is
properly pronounced after i read it
wrong i will
it's like [ __ ] impossible for me to
like rearrange it and like
because you've already memorized it the
wrong way yes i'm like because english
is a lot of memorization
full of words like that for me too even
though i'm a little what i want to be i
want you to be embarrassed
i've forgotten it's been so long so long
since i made a mistake
my embarrassments are so locked in that
i relive them so many times
like i'm so embarrassed i'm having a
good day
and then it'll be like remember five
years ago in front of everyone you said
i'm like i hate myself yeah i
don't deserve to live but fellas ladies
and gentlemen if you know the person
that you are trying to correct you
better walk
delicately with that person because i
tell you it is i was like it's craft
i don't care i don't know if it's a c or
a k i don't
care it's a ck i don't it's a crap
i was like who says a raft
at a bar no i'm asking for a crap and
plus the only time i use craft is when
i'm at denny's asking for some more
water can't get a crap for that like
they don't
know and then probably the waitress is
like
oh she don't know she's like you want to
share it
before you say yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah can i get a raft please oh
no i'm gonna use that in public would be
so bad
somebody's gonna watch this and probably
ask me you know i need a craft
a wrap okay well i think actually we're
gonna do
a whole episode coming up on
how to sound smart that's what i have
there we go for uh
not next week but the weekend
how to smell smart
waiting for them
so yes uh thank you for watching this
episode uh go check out
nikki street eats nikki's handle
honestly yeah
no chaser nicky what's the radio
big move shout out 997 in san francisco
or online big bay mornings check me out
monday through friday from 6 a.m to 10
a.m sure i ain't getting up at 6 a.m but
i'll go
you know what you can listen later to
the repeat the internet yes you can we
have a podcast
post it up every day after 11. nice
visit our sponsors if you want to
support the show the second best way to
support our show is to go leave us a
rating on itunes like just go ahead and
give us some stars write a couple words
that helps us out a lot
write some words we can spell write some
words and pronounce
just go go write craft and we'll know
you listen to this episode
and let us know in the comments uh if
there's anything that bothers you
yeah yeah about what you think about
what i guess it doesn't have to be about
men or
we were including all genders here so we
really were
anyways okay well we'll see you next
week thank you bye